after a day out of sight absorbing the
unfolding events the president emerged
to address the nation a tough day
with details of what had happened an
attack by a group known as isis k
took the lives of american service
members
standing guard at the airport and
wounded several others seriously as
president it was his decision which has
now resulted in such chaos and death but
he spoke as a father and a husband who
has experienced loss two children and a
wife we have some sense like many of you
do
what the families of these brave heroes
are feeling today
you get this feeling like you're being
sucked into a black hole
in the middle of your chest
there's no way out
my heart aches for you
and there was a warning for the
terrorists who carried out this attack
we will not forgive
we will not forget
we will hunt you down
and make you pay but the evacuation he
vowed would continue
earlier at the pentagon the generals
were frank about the ongoing threat a
car bomb a suicide attack or even a
rocket at an aircraft full of evacuees
or troops and a revelation that the
cooperation with the taliban now goes as
far as sharing intelligence
we share versions of this information
with the taliban so that they can
actually do some searching out there for
us and we believe that some attacks have
been thwarted by them
from behind this white house door in the
west wing president biden now has new
calculations new challenges and a
responsibility that he accepts is his
and so there was empathy there was
emotion but steadfastness from the
president too as commander-in-chief he
has now pledged to such conflicting
missions to continue with the evacuation
to get the troops out but also to hunt
down the terrorists that central
justification of his for pulling out
that afghanistan is no longer a home for
terrorists well that has now been proved
so tragically wrong
his pledge was to bring troops out of
harm's way but a mission he ordered and
defended has now taken the lives of so
many more american and afghan mark stone
sky news in washington